these MPS on the Privileges committee
who threw the book at Boris Johnson for
lying to Parliament have now done a new
report into Boris Johnson's allies who
they say carried out a campaign of
interference into the work they were
doing let me take you through what they
said and what it all means they start
off with a reason they say what needs to
be addressed is the campaign waged
outside Parliament by some members of
the House of Commons and the House of
Lords and they go on to name them to
undermine the committee they talk about
them using newspapers radio and social
media and they're particularly concerned
that these are very experienced
colleagues let's show you some of the
comments that they were so concerned
about here we've got a list of MPS
including Nadine Doris Jacob Reese smorg
pretty Patel people of former cabinet
ministers calling the inquiry into Boris
Johnson a kangaroo court and a Witch
Hunt they say future Generations will
look back in astonishment serious
questions one MP says need to be asked
about the manner in this which this
investigation was conducted in all they
named seven MPS and three peers here's
Jacob Reese Mark talking about kangaroo
courts we in fact caught up with Jacob
riesmorg this morning and this is what
he told us
I'm actually going to church because
it's the feast of Saint Peters and Paul
and the holy day of obligation that I
would encourage you all to do the same
and then I shall be at the Test match
which I'm looking forward
so you're not doing anything in
Parliament and we also caught up with
Michael fabricant uh MP who has tweeted
uh this this morning he is one of those
named and he says I stand by my
statement some of the members of the
Privileges committee treated their
witness Boris Johnson with contempt by
gestures and other actions now going
back to the report and what the
Privileges committee found they talk in
particular about the impact this was
going to have on the MPS on the
committee and they say that they they're
worried that there was going to be they
were trying to drive conservative MPS
out of the committee they say pressure
was applied particularly to conservative
members with a clear intention to drive
them out and frustrate the work of the
house and they also talked about how
this pressure had a serious personal
impact on individual members and raised
significant security concerns for them
as they concluded at their work so what
happens other than and face criticism of
the behavior of some of these allies
well they've asked the government to
make sure that the house that all MPS
note with approval this report so
they're asking the government to have a
vote and a debate on this report and
we've already heard that that is going
to be happening a week on Monday on the
10th of July so will Rishi sunak and
other senior members of cabinet turn up
for it and they say it will be for the
house to consider what further action
here is to be taken if any in respect of
this report so they're saying the MPS
can for example trigger individual
investigations into some of these MPS
and peers and then they might face a
sanction but all this just drags out
partygate and is a bit of a headache for
the Prime Minister as he heads into some
really significant by-elections